nous sommes allés au souk avec kelly et
il ya un moment où on avait prévenu
avait préparé un piège mais le piège est
tellement mal fait jean-michel n'était
pas au courant mais jean michel et moi
on comprend tout de suite qu'il ya un
piège et on est mort de rire tout le dos
et vous allez voir que kelly elle elle
continue sa douche
[Musique]
est ce que je veux
on part pour convaincre l'état n'a pas
du tout même niveau au frère je tresse
pas mais parce qu'il croit que je vais
jouer contre un club professionnel ces
cinq voire de la région
son métier sa palme et état d'état
mentor
deux voitures ne pense qu'à ça
pour la photo de ben c'est notre
émission
juste derrière c'est pas un piège
je connais un petit peu cyril quand même
un peu pratique tout petit peu les
méthodes du monsieur
mais je ne connais pas assez bien
[Musique]
c'est rien n'a rien t'as rien qui évite
à rien
[Musique]
tu
j'ai dit ça va ça va craquer je t'adore
et défaire les faire pour gagner
ils sont bien mer chauffée s'en sort
bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est le manager parisien
y'avait rochelle
[Musique]
les jouvencelles déstabiliser la
bonjour
[Musique]
ces chiens qui a filé c'est toi tu veux
pas d'entraîneur
[Musique]
on fait le malin voilà la mer on n'a
même pas pu filmer la balle tellement
levitte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et l'entraîneur champion à l'ordre
public voilà qui est plus beau gosse
ouais il est beau